this is a production of cornell
university
so again my name is daniel greenberg and
i'm founder and director of this
organization called living roots
and what i want to do is really briefly
talk about what our
ecovillages these sustainable
communities that we work with
and i'll just show one slide of each of
the places we go just to give you a
flavor of some of the communities
and then i really want to talk about why
we believe ecovillages
and sustainable communities make ideal
campuses to teach about sustainable
community development and i'll do a
comparison between
ecovillages and academia so and i
usually start off with some big
picture stuff state of the world climate
change peak oil carrying capacity
footprint i'm not going to do all that
because i'm just guessing i'm assuming
that i'm preaching to the converted here
that
you all understand that we're living in
a unique time not just in human history
but in planetary history
right good we're all on the same page
there okay so let's move on i don't have
to talk about the why so much
so there's a couple of ways into talking
about what ecovillages are
if this thing will start working you
have to
hang up close here
why isn't that working
it shows me give me a second
hmm
that's never happened before i mean oh
did it work out good
okay let's hope that works out so eco
villages in its simplest form
are just a group of people right and
they've come together and they're trying
to
model sustainable lifestyles they're
basically saying look we can't wait any
longer
we can't wait for governments to
legislate solutions we can't wait for
businesses to bring solutions to market
where are the best practices around the
world
from sustainable agriculture renewable
energy appropriate technology
local building materials all of that how
do we bring them together
into community scale solutions that work
for us
and for our environment right so they're
not utopias
and i really need to say that clearly
these are not perfect places i went
looking for them
i couldn't find them i still haven't
found any but they're trying
and as such we feel like they make these
ideal campuses to learn about
sustainable
development so another way to think
about ecovillages we're all aware of
this growing gap between the resource
rich
and the resource poor around the world
right and
most people when you talk to them or if
you're reading about sustainable
development we're talking about this
right how do we raise the quality of
life among the resource poor
which i mean i'm not arguing with this
at all i mean this is
critical work there are billions of
people living without
access to clean water education medical
facilities shelter
right absolutely this needs to happen
but what i don't hear
a lot of people talking about is what
are the goals what are the models what
are the limits to this kind of
development
and often if you scratch a little bit
just below the surface people will
respond well
i don't know i mean give us a break
we're trying to raise the quality of
life with people who really need it you
know
maybe if we're lucky we'll get to first
world standard lifestyles
you know this is a kind of a delicate
thing to say myself as a privileged
westerner
that this may not be possible because
the evidence is really clear that our
planet
can't support our present population of
around 7 billion
with our present lifestyles much less
the 9 or 10 billion
expected by 2040 all living first world
standard lights does all with a car in
the garage
it's just not going to happen and you
know it's not even up for us to decide i
mean
the earth is already giving us feedback
there are already consequences around
our global actions through
climate change and and peak oil and
everything so
we absolutely need to figure out where
are the goals
for resource poor to raise their quality
of life
and of course equally important if not
more important we need to figure out how
to reduce the ecological impact of the
resource rich
us i'm talking by large westernized
countries and you know we talk about
hybrid cars and compost and recycling
and all that good stuff important stuff
but i would suggest that if we're going
to get through this bottleneck
that i think we're facing as a species
we need to consider more
radical alternatives and so really what
ecovillages have done
is they've staked out this middle ground
between this growing gap
of the resource rich in the resource
board they're saying how do we raise
the resource poor above what someone
called the dignity
floor how do we allow everyone on the
planet to have a base
access to adequate wealth and resources
a sense of agency in their lives a sense
of well-being
right how do we get everyone above the
dignity floor and at the same time how
do we get everyone
below what someone called a profligacy
ceiling otherwise known as carrying
capacity right
this is our livable zone in here and we
all have to get in there
if we're going to survive if not thrive
as a species
and the sad truth is very few of us are
very few even the eco villages we go to
i'll show you a slide of finn horn
anyone here findhorn
plays a northern scholar or a couple
they're going to celebrate their 50th
anniversary next year they're probably
the grandmother the grandfather of the
contemporary eco village movement
and they're they're really on the
cutting edge of of what this is all
about
and there was a study done a couple
years ago looking at
their ecological footprint and what they
found was
the average member of finn horn had half
the ecological footprint they were using
half of
uh ecologically productive land and
water area than
an average uk citizen it was great you
know it made international press they
were lauded as the most sustainable
village in the
in the western hemisphere and
you know if everyone lived the way they
live at finhorn we'd still need more
than one planet
so here's finn horn on the cutting edge
of the ecovillage movement and they're
still not in this livable zone
so you know the sad truth is i really
think we're in kindergarten
as a species we're in kindergarten in
terms of where we need to be
in sustainable relationship to each
other in the planet you know eco
villages
maybe third fourth grade i don't know
you know but we need to get to middle
school high school
college we need to graduate because i do
think there are some exams coming
that we really want to pass and so
ecovillages are just
experiments they're beta test centers
they're saying how do we try to figure
this out
because we're going to have to figure
this out so that's a little bit about
ecovillages just really quickly about
living roots
we're an educational non-profit we
partner with the university of
massachusetts and amherst and we run
these study abroad programs based
in sustainable communities and eco
villages around the world
some quick background i actually was an
undergrad at cornell
and i started in electrical engineering
and then i shifted to psychology i
started teaching
computers to kids at giac downtown and i
realized i like kids more than computers
and and i started dreaming of creating a
school
for children in a community setting and
then i went to minnesota to do
doctoral work at the university of
minnesota in minneapolis
and i ended up doing my my doctoral
thesis
on children and growing up in communes
essentially
intentional communities and i studied
the topic probably two years
sent out surveys everywhere i could find
read everything i could find
and and then hopped into a westphalia
campervan with my then partner now wife
monique and we traveled to about 30
or 40 intentional communities communes
around north america
and i swear i think i learned more the
first
day i stepped foot in one of these
communities
than i did in those two years i had
spent studying i was like oh now i get
it
you know i suddenly understood it
viscerally and then i had to do a school
psychology
internship for my doctoral program and i
wrote around to communities and finhorn
this community in scotland wrote back
said yeah we could use some help with
our kids which they did
and so we moved there for a year and it
was an incredible experience really
amazing and in the middle of that year a
friend
brought over some college students from
i think it was prescott college
and they were there for a week maybe two
weeks but in that time
frame i saw each one of them like pop
you know their lives were transformed in
very much the same way that i felt when
i started traveling to communities
and i remember waking up with goosebumps
one night thinking oh this is
this is why i'm here it felt like on
that level of purpose
how do i build this bridge between
academia and these communities to help
more people have this experience of
of connection of interdependence
community
and so that was back in 92 and so the
last 20 years has really been about
doing this uh and i started
directing a program to south india to a
community called orville i'll show you
a slide of that and then in 98 i left
and 99 i started living roots
so it's been an amazing experience and
and blessing and privilege to be able to
do this work
these are the programs that we run
currently we do semester january and
summer programs
semester we go to finhorn in scotland uh
israel the
monteverdi institute in costa rica and
oroville in south india
and then in january we go to weiwei
kyoto a community in mexico
as well as oroville and india and then
in the summer we have programs in
peru high amazon approved called a
couple communities near
sorry a couple programs near the
community i live near called sirius
and brazil ecocentric epec and australia
and crystal waters
and there's others that we're looking at
there are probably about two thousand
self-identified ecovillages on the
planet and there's many more that just
don't self-identify that way i mean sri
lanka there's like 10
000 villages that are trying to develop
sustainably so
it all depends on how you define them
and where you draw the line but
to me this is some of the most exciting
news of the planet that there are people
just
doing it how do we figure this out in
community scale
so just to show you one picture of each
of these places this is the semester
program
at finhorn in scotland finhorn's way up
here on the north coast
of scotland right on the north sea about
a half hour east of inverness which
where the loch ness monster is supposed
to be it's a good 10 hours from
london by bus and again fin horn's going
to be celebrating its 50th anniversary
next november and there's about 450
people
from maybe 30 35 different nationalities
and their
what their motto is creating positive
visions for humanity and the planet
that's what they're about there's a
saying actually at fin horn that goes
work
is love and action work is love in
action
you know the idea being how do we how do
we raise our consciousness to the
highest level possible
and then how do we manifest that in the
world how do we bring that into the
world in everything we do
whether it's harvesting beets whether
it's building a building whether it's
you know cooking a meal or cleaning a
toilet and it shows you know there's a
there's a an attention to detail a sense
of aesthetic
that fin horn and i know just
being there i feel uplifted and it's
just really nice to be around people
that are really consciously trying to do
that i mean check it out this is their
conference hall and it was built mostly
out of
volunteer labor but you can't really see
probably from where you are but the
workmanship was exquisite
so there's really a lot of attention
there this is a nature sanctuary there's
one person's inspiration
built out of all found and recycled
materials turf roof this is a
house there's actually a whole bunch of
houses in this neighborhood and they're
all built out of old whiskey barrels
remember this is scotland right so i
mean there was a company moving from
wood vats to metal bats and i can't
remember if they were giving them away
for free or they someone in finland
bought them cheap and they were just
sort of piling up in a corner until this
guy roger
dude and looked at him and said you know
i could i could live in our live house
so he built this house and now there's a
couple two-story barrel houses it's like
out of a hobbit it's really amazing
um they also own this big hotel about
five miles away
they bought in the mid-80s for about a
hundred and fifty thousand dollars if
you can believe
it and it was a wreck and they've been
renovating it ever since they have
wonderful gardens
uh they weren't they're not really large
farms they but they do
provide and produce a lot of their own
food about 80 percent they do a lot of
work with
csas in the region um
and finland is actually quite known for
their their
gourmet meals there's a fin one cookbook
maybe some that's maybe some
how some people have heard about finland
so on this program
and a lot of our programs the courses
are really looking at our relationships
i talk a lot about relational pedagogy
our relationships with each other so we
have a community dynamics course
communication skills all that and then
we have an ecology course
what is anika village what are the
successes challenges of finnhorn state
of the world stuff
and then also a worldview course
to really deconstruct some of the
stories
and cultural values that got us to where
we are now
you know why how is it that we've become
this juggernaut of destruction as a
species
and what are our options and how do we
even think about that
so it's really an opportunity for
students to step back and reflect on
a lot of deep deep values the programs
we go to the communities eco-villages we
go to they're not religious communities
but i would say that they're spiritual
in the sense that they're really asking
those big questions meaning
purpose why are we here what are we
going to do about it and then there's a
service course too to allow students an
opportunity to really get involved
and do stuff so in israel there's a
there's actually a small group of
kibbutzim called the green kibbutz
movement
uh maybe a dozen
a couple of them live are down in the
negev in the ira the desert
of israel so this is one this is
probably the most active of them called
kibbutz lothan
and this is a reformed jewish kibbutzim
and
they've been around for 20 or so years
and you know they wanted to form a
kibbutz and so they went to the
government of israel and they said sure
we'll give you some land and they're
like wait a minute we don't want
anything that's in dispute
any land in dispute they said finally in
the desert
and they were there for like 10 years
you know and kind of just doing their
thing
and then they slowly started waking up
to the fact that they were in the desert
and they're like
why are we here and why do we have cows
this is kind of crazy you know
but they really took it on and they've
done a lot of work with permaculture is
that a familiar concept to most people
okay if it's not i can explain a little
bit later um they do
they students have actually helped build
their own dormitories uh
you know they do a lot of work with
natural building the government of
israel will build these like cement
block houses which in the desert just
are awful buildings so these breathe
they do a lot of work with solar and and
natural building
they have a wonderful bird sanctuary uh
it's just a really amazing place but if
you get up into these hills and you look
down it's just this oasis
it's just this little dot in the desert
but they're really trying to figure out
how they can
bring back life there um so
and on this course there's a peace and
social justice pro of course the
students really have an opportunity to
get involved with
uh palestinians arab israelis better
ones and really try to see the situation
through multiple lenses
that is what we feel how peace is going
to come to the region it's not about
who's right and who's wrong it's about
how many stories can we hold
at once there's a permaculture course
appropriate technologies and there's
also a communications course here but
we're trying to turn that into a
community economics course costa rica we
have a program in the
at the monteverdi institute in the cloud
forest tropical ecology
uh there's a spanish course there
is a service learning course um
and did i say peace and social justice i
think those are the fourth
so this is a a semester program that
we've been running in costa rica
india this is another one of my favorite
places in the world this is a community
called oroville it's down in the south
uh three hours south of chennai very
close to ponetre right on the bay of
bengal and it's a large community it's
about 2 200 people
about 45 different nationalities
incredibly international
and they are building as they call it a
city the earth needs
a sustainable city their dream is to
become a city for 50 000 people
it's some it's a large area it's about
fourteen square kilometers
and about a little less than half of
that membership are from they're from
india and the rest are from around the
world
um and so orville is essentially this
big experiment uh the there were two
founders srirabindo and a woman mirror
alfalfa one thing that
sri abindo died in 1950 the one thing
that he talked about a lot
was how he believed humanity is on the
brink of an evolutionary leap
in consciousness and he wasn't talking
about like the 60s or just you know
certain
but he's talking about this time and i
like to believe that you know we have to
really
think about how do we change how we
think about things if we're going to
survive
as a species and so orville is basically
made up of people who say yeah
and i believe that i want to believe
that what do we do
how do we do that you know how would we
create a city a vessel a container
for this new consciousness to emerge so
it's really this radical sometimes
chaotic experiment
they do reinvent the wheel a lot but
they're very creative and they're trying
to do different things
there's like 13 different organic farms
using all different methods
there's french intensive there's there's
one farm based on
fukuoka's one straw revolution from
japan um
permaculture there's a lot of stuff
going on this building down here
looks like the epcot center but it's a
meditation hall
and it's a place for people to go and
just be silent it's not a place for
religion or dogma or even groups it's
just a place to be silent
this is a big solar dish probably twice
the size of this room
and it collects the sun's rays and it
super heats water
the steam of which is used to cook 1200
meals a day
so this is like community scale
appropriate technology it's not
technology for an individual it's not
technology for the a metropolitan area
how do we create technology that we can
live with
in groups and i think that's an area
that is
needs a lot of development and i think
that's one of the places that
ecovillages are really pushing the edge
there's nothing i've ever found in anika
village in terms of technology
that you can't find being done better
elsewhere i mean you know there are
better windmills elsewhere there are
better
organic farms there are better leeds
buildings and all that
ecovillages aren't pushing the edge of
individual technologies
what ecovillages are doing is they're
saying how do we put the pieces together
into cultures into stories into into
real life communities where we can live
these lives because that's where we need
to go and because of that they're
looking at how do we do this
economically
uh and ways that fit for us and the
environment
okay so and then we have a couple short
programs
a lot of them around permaculture if
you're not familiar with permaculture
it's a system of ecological
design basically asking how does nature
design
what are the principles of design that
we can discern from nature and then how
would we apply those principles
to the human built environment started
in australia
gosh what maybe 40 years ago i think i'm
not exactly sure it started as a
concatenation of permanent
agriculture how do we create
agricultural systems
that don't need constant human input but
that are just naturally
uh sustainable and it's evolved into now
today it's more often thought of as
permanent culture so it's be
it's gone beyond agriculture and it's
looking at the built environment and
social systems
and economics even and it's become quite
popular around the world i've lost track
but i would guess
probably 40 or 50 000 people around the
world have gone through a permaculture
design
course and so there is a fairly
structured curriculum
we expand on that because we base these
in communities and we want to really
include that aspect as well
but we're really happy to be able to do
that and so one of the places we go to
is a
community called eco central epec and
it's in the serato of brazil
southwest of brasilia and
this is a community that was designed
using these permaculture principles
and then we have a six-week program in
peru you remember that that's line i
showed you before with sort of resource
rich in resource poor if you think about
it that way there's really two
directions toward ecovillages
in the resource-rich areas like here
people are developing equal villages
saying how do we maintain a high quality
lifestyle but reduce our footprint
ecovillage
is an excellent example of that right
and then there's
uh there's eco villages from resource
poor worlds where they're saying how do
we
increase our quality of life but
maintain a light footprint so that's an
example in peru
india is really interesting because
india is kind of in oracle they're kind
of doing both
because it's so international there is
sort of that western mentality but
there's also a very strong indigenous
mentality there too
so here there's a six-week program we do
a course in spanish and quechua which is
the non-colonial language
and also looking at biocultural
regeneration so shamanism
and fair trade coffee
and they work with what are called
mountain microorganisms i don't know a
whole lot about them but they i think
they
they cultivate them for mushrooms in the
forest and then it's used as a way to
fertilize the fields and they see it as
a potential alternative to slash and
burn agriculture
so they do a lot of work around that too
so it's a really amazing opportunity in
the high amazon peru
and then this is where i live at in the
western
in western massachusetts is a community
called sirius and notice how it's
spelled it's like the dogs turn up
serious and it's a spin-off of fin horn
and so
sirius has been around six seventy-eight
so is that maybe about 34-35 years old
and it's a smaller community there's
maybe 20 members but there's a larger
wider community around it of maybe 150.
this is the community center the back
side with a wonderful greenhouse
and this is the upstairs here and so
this is the classroom that the students
take over for three weeks it's really
wonderful
and students go into design teams
and they learn these permaculture
principles and then they work with
clients either at sirius or in the
surrounding area
of applying these principles to the
needs that are expressed
and then we have a january program in
mexico at a community called way way
kyoto they have a fun story they were
basically uh
traveling troubadours they were doing
performance art uh
and theater throughout central and south
america i think they were called the
the illuminated elephant or something
and they were going around on buses and
then they got tired of that
and they settled here in mexico and they
got really good at decision making
and and facilitation facilitating group
process and so that's what we do our
course on there
looking at conflict and communication
styles and decision making etc
but there's a still strong art and
theater focus there
and then when we can we get to australia
the birthplace of permaculture to this
community called crystal waters
which is another community design using
these principles um
there's various reasons why we haven't
been there for a while max lindager
is one of the best permaculture teachers
i know he's been teaching it for like 30
years
okay so that gives you a a little kind
of visual
sense of some of the ecovillages that
are out there i want to shift now and
talk a little bit about why
ecovillages make really good campuses
for sustainability education
is there any any thoughts questions up
until now
um i noticed in the upcoming
eco villages that you were gonna work
with there was a
one of the ones that was twin oaks is
that the one in virginia yes
yeah that's a little lower on our radar
right now um originally i was thinking
of it'd be great to do a program based
at earth haven
in north carolina and then maybe do
trips to twin oaks and the farm
i think that would be a possible thing
the problem is is it's pretty expensive
to run a program in the u.s yeah and so
it actually cost about the same
as a program in india and you talk to a
student like well you could go to
virginia or india
and so it's been nice it is it's it's
hard to
attract people right yeah yeah
anything else yeah
to bounce off that are you finding that
students internationally are interested
in coming to the us
um they are occasionally we haven't
that's a whole other world
that we haven't really we haven't looked
at um
that if we were to develop more we do
want to develop a semester program
actually locally
uh at sirius and in the pioneer valley
that area the happy valley the tofu
curtain
massachusetts and if we were to do that
we were thinking both to connect more
deeply with the five colleges umass
amherst and the four colleges around it
smith mount holyoke
amherst and hampshire thank you
um and we thought maybe that would be a
really interesting opportunity to
attract international students to come
to that
so yeah anything else
okay so let's talk just for a few
minutes and then we just open up for
some discussion around
uh what i want to do is sort of dissect
the hidden curriculum
between academia and ecovillages and
what do i mean by this
it's talked about in a number of ways
this guy chet bauer talked about the
meta-narratives of the systems that
we're involved with
you know when you go to cornell you're
learning a lot hopefully
in the classes you take but i would
suggest you're also learning a lot
from just participating in the system
there is a hidden curriculum that we
learn just by being a part of
groups and systems so i mean simple
things you know sit up straight
pencil down eyes ahead don't cheat you
know all these things
are rules that we learn by being part of
the system
and so what i want to do is sort of make
a comparison between what i see as some
of those the hidden
agenda hidden curriculum of academia
versus ecovillages and
before i do that i just want to say i'm
really painting the
the the ends of the spectrum here so it
may be a little provocative i hope it is
you know and i hope you don't agree with
everything i say
but i just want to put it out there and
maybe some of it will resonate and some
of it won't and we'll we can talk about
it okay
so just to get into it for example
academia is conventional
right i mean the basic structure of
academia has not changed since
the middle ages yeah you know you just
walk around and a lot of the structures
of
how things are here things are slow to
move they're very bureaucratic
i know i felt that when i was at cornell
um
whereas ecovillages are experimental
right there
they are laboratories they if something
doesn't work you just can shift on a
dime
and so they tend to be a little bit more
nimble about how to think about things
and how to
how to look at things okay academia is
hierarchical
right i mean power emanates from the
president and provos down to deans and
faculty
and you know students are at the low run
here right
um and it really is telling a story of
power over submission to authority
and so it's not such a big leap to be in
an institution like this and then go out
and say well we have to subjugate nature
we have to apply that story that i
learned viscerally through
participating in this institution to
what i'm doing in the natural world
right whereas ecovillages tend to be
more heteroarchical that is a word i
looked it up
um and so people in inca villages tend
to interact more on a peer level
and you know you you there's not so much
uh a power over
uh it's really working with uh academic
whoops sorry yeah academia is
competitive through and through right i
felt this a lot at cornell it was a
great place it is a great place
but i felt it intensely competitive so
students for
grades right faculty for tenure grants
recognition schools for endowments uh
you know and recognition so it's just it
infiltrates it's throughout the whole
system and
not to say that competition is
completely foreign villages but they
tend to be
more cooperative they tend to say how is
the success
of the individual tied to the success of
the whole
how can we really support each other and
and
you know the idea of cheating doesn't
make sense in the real world it's called
collaboration you know it's like
how to and yet we come out of schools
thinking you can't you can't trade you
know
information but that's where what really
happens and that's how
we move forward academia is fragmented
right we talk about this silo mentality
in ecovillage in academia
and we talk about rigor and when i think
of that i think of sort of two
dimensions of rigor
in traditional academia there's very
much a vertical rigor and so it's like
how much can you dive into
one topic and really dig down as far as
you can go into one
particular sub sub topic which is great
i mean i'm not denying that's
interesting stuff
but all the interesting stuff that i
know about happening in academia is
almost all transdisciplinary
it's all happening across the fields and
so
ecovillages are inherently looking at
a more lateral rigor it's not to say
that there's any
less quality of engagement there's any
less critical reflection
but it's looking at how do we bridge
these disciplines how do we think across
ideas you know you put up a windmill and
what are you talking about you're
talking about engineering you're talking
about
regional planning you're talking about
um
social systems and decision making and
governance i mean all these disciplines
come to bear in the natural in the real
world
and so let's just use those as real life
experiments
and and opportunities to learn
academia is proximal what do i mean by
that
well you know in schools from from the
beginning
up through mostly it changes a little
bit but through college and grad school
we tend to be age segregated we tend to
have very mediated
relationships so you are all in a class
together you have relationship with your
faculty maybe
a faculty advisor but they're all
through certain ways of being
and you kind of know the rules right
whereas
in in eco villages they tend to be more
intimate relationships and people
interact with each other in a lot of
different ways you might be
farming with someone one day you might
be cooking with them another day or in a
in a meeting or a decision making
process or something and you get to know
people
in the fullness of life and i think
that's really important and
remember when i said when i started
traveling to communities i had this sort
of epiphany when i when i started going
to these communities
i think what was happening was
it was almost like there was this need
in me that i didn't even know was there
and it started getting filled up and it
was a very confusing experience for a
little while and what i
now label that need as is community it's
belonging
and i really think that we have lost
a sense of community at least in the
western world i think we've lost a sense
of community so profoundly
that most of us don't even think of it
as something to strive for
to look for you know when i was at
cornell you know a lot of late-night
discussions around
how we want to live our lives what kind
of parents we want to be what kind of
work we want to do in the world
and um you know maybe we might need to
be making lists well you know what do
you want to get out of life
and if you think about that you know
what shows up on those lists a lot well
i want to i want a good job
i want a loving partner living in a nice
house
opportunities to travel maybe learn more
you know all that's great but the idea
of belonging
to a community i mean honestly doesn't
it sound a little
old-fashioned it's almost vaguely
religious you know it's like
i don't know it sounds a little scary
but really you know and a lot of people
when i talk about eco villages they're
like yeah all right but you know they're
really kind of weird
i mean they are a little weird i'll
grant them you know
they're they're irrelevant they're
marginal they really don't have anything
to say
to our society and when i hear that
i i ask i reflect back and say you know
i encourage you to take a step back
and take a more evolutionary perspective
and remember
that for 99.9 of our evolutionary
history
we lived in community we lived in tribes
right i mean this is in our bones it's
in our genes
we are viscerally wired to be social
animals
and it's really only been since the
industrial revolution
that we've gotten away from that why how
well because we've accessed the cheap
energy yeah i can live in the suburbs
and i can drive to the mall i can go get
my food at the grocery store i don't
have to interact with anyone
because it's cheap
but i think we've lost something
profound in that
you know and so when i started traveling
to communities it was like
wow oh yeah there's a sense of belonging
and and that's what i see sort of wake
up
in the students that go on these
programs too or spend time in eco
villages
and to me it that's not just about
a sense of well-being and happiness
around thinking about
community and belonging i also think
it's fundamental to the sustainability
of our planet
i i don't think we could do what we do
to each other
i don't think we could do what we do to
the planet
if we fundamentally felt i belong here
you belong here that desert belongs here
we have to figure this out together you
know if i
if i had to boil this all down to one
word
it would be interdependence actually
how many of you ever heard of tiknot han
the buddhist monk a couple people
anything he's written is worth reading
actually let me let me get back to that
because i think it's
going on i'll i'll mention in a minute
down here
so getting back to uh well let me just
say so
community i really think it's it's
foundational and
it does exist in academia you know a lot
of people come to college to have that
sense of the academic community
so i'm not dissing that i think that
there's something valuable there i just
say i just think there's so much more
and i encourage each of you wherever you
are in your lives
to be thinking about who's your tribe
you know who do you belong to who
belongs to you
because i really think we're moving
toward a place when that's essential and
we need to be thinking about that
so okay academia it's very theoretical
right it's very um
armchair theoretician um you know
it tends to train people in their heads
i wrote a blog entry a while ago that if
i
had to choose blindly between two
candidates to teach on one of our
programs and one was a master's level
and one was a phd
i'd probably choose the masters and that
doesn't make me many friends
in academia but the reason is is that
master's level folks tend to get the
degree because they want to get out
there and do stuff
right people who go on to phds
tend to be a little more in their heads
and i'm making
grand generalizations here okay so
forgive me i i know i've got a phd
myself
um but i i think and and phd programs
even tend to
train armchair pediatricians right and
in my graduate program
in minnesota i was astonished it was a
program in child development and school
psychology
how little of it had to do with being
with kids
i mean they were it was all laboratory
and it was
crazy and the best thing i did in my
graduate program besides my dissertation
was i got an early ed teaching
certificate and i actually went into the
preschool and i
and i worked with the kids and all my
colleagues were like why would you do
that
you know it's kind of messy you know
like yeah but it was fun so i mean
i think there is this weird
kind of separation between what we
think of in academia and what is
actually in the real world
so what does it say is the meaning of
life true false multiple choice essay or
what you know
uh equal villages are applied if it
doesn't work you try something else
it's really about how do we bring this
knowledge into
real life academia
is secular so i'll get back to this
concept in a second so
you know there's this idea
this myth of objectivity that we can
somehow study the world but not
influence or be a part of it
and in ecovillages i use the word
spiritual but
i know it's a loaded term but i think of
it in terms of the big questions again
why are we here purpose meaning
and to me again the word that i would
use is interdependence or better yet
the word that take not han coin which is
inter-being
and if you hear that word inter-being
and i think it's a wonderful word you
know the idea is like how do we see
the clouds in our textbooks
you know how do we see it all connected
together
if there's anything that science has
shown
in the last 150 years it's that
everything is connected
you know and it's funny i was at a
conference uh a couple of years ago
asia it's the association for the
advancement of sustainability and higher
education
and i was at a workshop that was sort of
an advanced level workshop
and it was called competencies
core competencies in sustainable
education so this was people who've been
involved in the field for a long time
getting together saying okay
let's teach about sustainability what
are the core things we want students to
come away with what do we want them to
know and we got into
into tables and we started talking and i
was the first one to
to say something at my table and i said
look this is good
i think we should do this but before we
do it i
just want us to recognize that
we're jumping into the what and i think
we should take a step back
and reflect on the why because if we
talk
just about competencies and what we want
students to know how to do
we're missing a huge thing which is
really about
the why there's a there's a woman joanna
macy
anyone hear of her she was a nuclear
activist systems thinker
buddhist scholar also anything she's
written is worth reading
she talks about this great turning
toward an ecological age that we're
in hopefully now and she says there's
three things driving this turn
the first of what she calls holding
actions this is slowing the bad
right this juggernaut of destruction
that we've become as a species how do we
stop
all that stuff from rainforest
destruction and um
you know the keystone xl all this stuff
how do we slow and stop the stuff that's
really hurting the planet
but something she said that was really
powerful to me she says it's not
enough and at that time i think i was
reading her when i was a student and i
was
part of some of the activism here i was
arrested in day hall we were doing
shanty towns we were trying to get
cornell to divest and it was very much
you know that kind of burnout kind of
we're just going to make the change
happen
we got to stop all this and when i read
that it was like
wow yeah we need to do more and
the two other things she says we need to
create new we need to create new
institutions across the map we need to
create new economic institutions new
educational institutions
new forms of community new ways of
learning all of this we need to recreate
for a post-oil post-carrying capacity
world because if we don't create the new
we're just going to go back to the bad
but the really powerful thing she said
is even that's not enough
she said there's one more thing that
really drives it all and that's really
world views
stories how do we think about who we are
and so for me it really comes down to
this idea of inter-being
and i actually think it's something we
can all get behind and what i was
astonished at is getting back to that
table that roundtable where we were
talking about core competencies
is i shared this i said really for me
the why
is we're all interconnecting we have to
come from that place and the guy across
the table for me looked at me said yeah
you know that's all good
but really that's your value you know
and i don't think we should be teaching
our personal values in education and i
was like
you know i mean these were like the
elite
of people working in sustainability in
higher education
and he thought interdependence was just
a value
and i was like whoa we really are in
kindergarten there's a long way to go
but so
i get flack for talking about
spirituality but i really think it's
core
because i think this is how we need to
reorient what we teach
and really look at how are we connected
to everything around us
okay almost there academia large
footprint i barely need to say this
right i mean you just walk around
cornell and it's like whoa
and you know elite colleges universities
they've got to have their expansive
lawns and their cutting edge
uh science facilities and all that and
that's all fine but we also need to
recognize
what it actually does to the environment
and cornell's doing some great stuff
around sustainability and
i had dinner with my friend dan roth the
other day he's doing great work here
but really ecovillages start from this
they say how can we live a light
footprint from the beginning this is
i showed you the nature sanctuary at
finhorn
last but far from least academia i
tend to find is fairly problem oriented
and
i think it's changing but i know that
even just maybe 10 years ago
there were lots of environmental studies
and science courses that were basically
litanies of
the problems in the world and i can't
tell you how many students have come to
us
kind of overwhelmed in grief sometimes
they're almost
numb because they're like i get it
you know i've read the books i've seen
the movies i understand what's going on
and and no one's talking about what
we're going to do about it
and and and for many students the only
way they can deal with that
is to shut down because it's too big
it's like wow you know so
to be able to see communities that are
actually
working towards solutions working toward
a place that we can actually live well
and and happy together
is just such a breath of fresh air i
mean it was for me and i i think it is
for students as well
so and i i honestly don't think
the world is going to shift towards
sustainability out of fear i mean
we all know what's going on there's a
lot of scary stuff in the world now
and i actually i honestly think we're
sort of approaching a fork
as a species on one path
there's the bunker mentality right this
is the predominant story
of our culture of certainly nations
that we're gonna protect our own we're
gonna get our bomb shelter we're gonna
put food there i'm gonna get my guns
and i'm going to you know have my
boundaries if you come and you try to
get what
what's mine i'm going to get you right i
really think that if we go down that
path
we will go extinct as a species
but i think there's another path and
that's the path of community without the
compassion of generosity
you know and i think if we go down that
path
that's where i think this could be the
most exciting time
for humanity i really do that
these aren't perfect solutions these are
the
we're in process and i i think that
ecovillages and sustainable communities
are just trying to push that envelope
and for me being a part of that has been
incredibly fulfilling and i find that
for
for students as well okay
that's that's basically it um we've got
some time i think yeah
so let's let's talk i mean you can take
this information down i've got
things actually if you want to be on our
mailing list i can put this around it's
kind of
anti-climactic but
we send out newsletters and stuff but
really let me let me actually go back
here and let me actually also i'll get
some
for sure so yeah i mean we can ask some
specific questions do you guys have
questions about the talk but um yeah
we'd like to do a
sort of discussion
um you know if you're shy
raise your hand and you can get your
name if you're trying to speak out
yeah you know um for everybody so i
guess
are there any questions now first of all
anna
um that's amazing you're very good right
now
um well i was
i was living in an intentional community
in west virginia
and definitely um
where was it was
and i definitely felt while i was there
was maintaining
a population through generations yeah
um so they had started in the 70s and it
was really strong for 20 years
and then people are 18 and they go to
college and
not a lot of people came back um and so
it seems like for the past
it's i guess it's 40 or 50 years now
it's been going on for the past 20 it's
a lot of adults
yeah and that just doesn't seem like you
can have a
sustainable community without all
generations
so i'm curious if you've seen any
villages that
have found a solution to that or are
also struggling
i mean at least they were having babies
right i mean the shakers
you gotta start there uh and it is an
issue in a lot of
a lot of communities um and it's natural
in a way because you think i mean
these communities are really radical and
it takes a lot of
ideological fervor among the founders
to do something that radical and we
can't expect our kids
to do that and actually it's often the
opposite because kids
often want to do the opposite of what
their parents are doing i often think oh
well
living roots my dream is to have this be
sort of a communiversity
by the time my kids are in college and
of course they're going to want to be
stock brokers or something like that
um so it is an issue
and there's a couple ways that i found
that communities that have been
successful that have dealt with it one
is
they've created layers of the onion so
example
sirius where i live my wife and i were
members
for a year and then what happened we had
kids and i started living roots
and to be a member at serious you have
to give eight hours a week of community
service
and go to the thursday night meetings
and it got to be a point where my wife
monique was saying you ain't going to
those meetings anymore
you know you're here at home with the
kid and we just didn't have the time
and that's a challenge in a lot of
communities that it's difficult for
families
and professionals to really be there but
what we did was we moved across the
street
and a lot of other people did the same
thing and so we live in this incredibly
community-minded neighborhood
and we i created these a little time
share for
for child care and we just you know we
just share a lot of resources
so that's one way that it happens is
that people just move one step outside
of the community but they still stay
engaged another way is that they get big
so finnhorn and oroville are big enough
where
the youth feel like they can kind of
rebel
but still stay part of the community so
and orville there's still enough
growing edges that young people can say
i'm going to make my mark over here and
i'm not going to have to feel like i'm
just carrying on what my parents did
right that's one of the the challenges
finnhorn what's happening is a lot of
the youth
go away and then they come back and
that's been been happening a lot
too and you know a lot of communities
just
exist on people coming and going and
they recognize that there's gonna be
a core group of people that are there
for a long time and then there are
people who
kind of come and go
yeah it's a big issue you can read my
thesis on children and community
thoughts and i happen to carry on to
that that's it
can i can i say something more about
kids and communities since you kind of
brought it up and it is that's a passion
of mine
um if i could go back and if i could do
my thesis
again i mean it was a wonderful thing
but i really bit off way more than i
could chew i was basically looking at
children in education and community i
mean it was
there was nothing that escaped my
attention um
something i found fascinating that i
think deserves a lot more
research is for our thank you the
relationships
that children are able to form in
community
with adults that aren't their parents
that aren't their teachers aren't their
friends parents or their friends parents
but are just friends
you know and i don't know how many of
you had that growing up i didn't
there was no adult in my life that was
just a friend
in community it's the norm and
i think that's such a powerful thing and
i think it's something so sad that we've
gotten away from that
in our society and i'm so grateful that
my kids have been able to grow up in a
place where they can walk to their
friends
houses and they just know that their
friends houses are their houses and and
it's all just and they just know the
area and
they feel like they're part of this
tribe and
if it's our goal which i hope it is to
help develop
global citizens people with a sense of
belonging to the whole planet
i can't think of a better foundation for
that
than to grow up in a community where you
have strong relationships with people
beyond your
your own family and yeah i mean i
i was in child care and it was weird you
know this was again the 80s i was
working in preschools and as a man
i would get one of two types of feedback
one was
oh you know it's so great you're a guy
you know when my kids get to hang out
with a guy you know and the other one
was like
you know why are you here what are you
doing and like you know neither of those
were seeing me
if you know i could be a good child care
provider or a bad child care provider
but they didn't they didn't see that
so and i think part of that is just
because we don't live in a culture where
this is normal
so i i i think kids in communities
is key i don't know maybe there weren't
that many kids in the community
no i was the youngest person so
for sure i think most of the kids have
lost about five years before
yeah they're really struggling with that
one one last thing on that is it was
interesting that when we started running
programs at findhorn
they were nervous at first because at
finhorn if you look at the
the demographics there was this dip from
18 to 25 because
they're all gone they all go to college
and when we and we
said we're going to bring some college
students they were like ah they're going
to make a mess you know because they did
um but they also found there was this
like
filling up they're like oh this feels
good because it actually
we need that kind of energy here so yeah
thanks yeah i don't know your name um so
anzac exactly just the
curiosity do you think that population
density
has an impact on community say morning
i'm sorry say more i'm curious where
you're going all right so i kind of did
grow up in the
rural farming community um did the 4-h
program um you know new neighbors
i guess if you could kind of compare it
i grew up
almost in the 60s without the drugs
and i was just wondering if you felt
that that could be an
uh factor is population density as a
like a town becomes a city does it
become less of a community
that's that's an interesting question
and one of the things that
i look for in the communities we take
students to
is that it has to be grockable you know
it has to be of a size where you
feel like you can get to know most
people in that community and maybe more
importantly you can become known
in that community there's no set number
on that
some say it's a hundred some say it can
go up to a thousand
um maybe over time but i do think that
there is a natural resonance that we
have
in groups that are knowable and
and so we've often thought oh it'd be
great to do a
semester program in an urban area and
there's a lot of great things happening
but i haven't found the way to do it
that
has that magic component of waking
students up to that sense of community
what you're saying is
a magic number hasn't really or a magic
stocking density
the magic population isn't really known
it's just
it's more of a quality of community
rather than a
density yeah i mean what happens often
like orville which i said is this large
community about 2200
they have naturally just broken into
smaller communities
so in some ways they're best thought of
as like a township and so there's maybe
a hundred communities that range from
five people to 100 people or so and so
but they're all part of this other
community so i think that's where we
need to go
is thinking about those layers of the
onion you know who is my
intimate group that i'm really working
with and living with day to day
and then who's that other group that i'm
making decisions with that maybe i'm
part of some collectives with conscious
collaborative consumption
whether it's csas trading things like
that and then how are we part of
something larger
but that we actually feel a sense of
agency in that too i think that could go
up and even into cities
yes sure i have a very unrelated sort of
logistical question sure how do people
in eco villages
um handle getting medical care or
healthcare
um um i mean i you know i wear glasses
and
yeah i like to go to the dentist yeah
you know people that would have you know
disabilities
sure or uh or you know diseases and
ailments and such
how do they get access to them i mean
these are rational people so and they're
pragmatic so i mean we're not expecting
every eco village to have
a hospital an airport uh you know
and so there are often health facilities
in
the at least the larger communities and
even the smaller ones you kind of know
who to go to
i mean my wife is a midwife and so
people know things around that or
um you know homeopathic and things like
that so there's a lot of just
local wisdom and knowledge but things
like that yeah they go to the doctor
they go to
wherever they need to go take care
and that's the world we live in you know
and actually you remember i said that
study that was done at finhorn that
showed that it had half the ecological
footprint
it was only that high because of their
travel
because there's a lot of people at
finnhorn who are fairly known in the
world and they go out and do workshops
and they're flying and they're
driving and taking buses and trains and
that that's what up their
footprint and that's because we just
live in a world that there's a fossil
fuel economy that we can't really get
away from at this point
right so yeah you do what you need to do
um also unrelated i really liked your
comment about recognizing that you
enjoyed kids more than computers
i realized quite a while ago that i
prefer trees over people
but i also realize that uh you can't get
rid of people
right so i'm balancing my own
my own perspective on life and what's
right for me as a person
and my ideologies and etc and
realizing that what i would like to
start focusing on is the short list of
things that i don't agree with
and learning how to how to somewhat
capitalize off of them how do i take
that negative energy of hey i don't
really like people but i like trees
well why not teach young people about
trees you know just sort of taking
a different stance on it um
so that's sort of where uh i really like
the comment that you made because
sometimes it's just
recognizing the simplicities of putting
things in a categories and i think that
this alone
uh everything on on the right side
speaks to me and always has
and i think also you said something
about
um feeling that void that you feel like
you've had
and i think at the point that i came to
cornell i started to recognize that much
more
how i would be an advocate of academia
and yet since i'm so unconventional
i feel uncomfortable in that type of
setting
and yet that the correlation of
different disciplinaries and
collaborative work
that's where the rubber meets the road
you're right that in the real world
that's what it takes to make
things happen is multiple people around
a large table
all coming from a different perspective
and then being able to come together and
devise those solutions
so that's you know in the in short what
academia taught me but i think i learned
that long before i came here
and it took coming here for me to
recognize that i knew that
yeah this is what i'm saying yeah i had
to do all that in trees
well it's just an example yes it's just
um for me it was the recognition of
where my love of the environment and my
love of art
met together at um at a specific point
in my life and that was before i came
before
right so i'm building off of that it's
it's putting things together
it's being creative it's been
spontaneous
and sometimes compromises too i mean
you know that what that struck in me was
that um
you can imagine a core dilemma of this
business this or this organization under
roots is that
here we are an organization all about
sustainability and yet what are we doing
i mean we're flying people all over the
world there's something really weird
about that
and i honest i strongly believe that the
impact that we make on students is
lifelong and it far exceeds
um the the impact of the program in fact
a friend actually did a study he does a
semester program in like an ecological
semester in costa rica
yeah and he saw he found that
students ecological footprint for that
semester
was lower in costa rica including the
impact from their their flights
than what it would have been if they
just stayed on campus so that's like
yeah and that's not true of all the
places but going it's a big way to go to
india but once they're there they're
living really light lifestyles
but one of the things that we've done is
we have always been committed to
measuring and reducing and
somehow uh measuring reducing and
somehow mitigating our carbon impacts
and
planting trees is a big place that we do
that so
um tree planting is a strong component
in all of their programs and really
connecting the trees
there was a cyclone did i mention this
that went through india recently did any
of you see this
it went it was uh just before the new
year and went right through oroville
and cyclone vane and it was like a
hundred year event
and just ripped up in some areas 40
years
of reforestation work are just gone and
um
i mean they're a resilient community
they'll come back and they're do and the
silver lining actually is that
in the early days folks in oroville
showed up and there was this desert
and they just started planting trees
what did they plant it's a tree called
the acacia auriculoforma
it's a kind of eucalyptus and it was
really good at digging into this
really kind of like hard baked soil it
was like terra cotta
you know and this tree was really good
at breaking that up and making it
available for other trees to follow
and then other trees showed up and
interestingly in this cyclone most of
the trees that came down
were those what they call the work trees
and so now the tropical dry evergreen
forest is really there
and so it's kind of cool it's like yeah
it was devastated but what's left
is what should be there but yeah
other thoughts questions how are we
doing four times we got to 4 20.
um or less 4 15 maybe i think there's
some people that are coming in
tomorrow
so this is a great presentation that you
don't see much anymore
and this also came out of that
ideological fervor of the founders you
know they
they had these big dreams they're saying
wait a minute and this is also true twin
oaks which you were mentioning too they
they remodeled themselves after the
kibbutz
and they said just because you have a
kid doesn't mean you're going to be a
great parent
so why don't we find the people who are
really good at with kids
and have them raise the kids right i
mean there's something theoretical that
makes sense
but practically it didn't work you know
i mean to separate that bond between
children and parents and so it maybe
lasted a generation or two
but you don't find that anymore but in
terms of that
question of too much community um you
know ever
i mean communities are made up of people
and there's all different types of
people and i find there's often
continuums
uh in any community one of those
continuums i find
is that on one end there's the people
who are saying
look i don't care how long it takes i
don't care how long we sit here
we're going to work this through we'll
be up all night and we're going to come
out with a decision you know or
and just as long as we all feel good
about it right and then there's people
on the other end of the spectrum they're
saying i don't want another
damn meeting you know i just want to go
build something all right
you know and and people exist on those
ends of the con
the spectrum and they often butt heads
right
you know another spectrum i find is that
there are people who come to a community
because they like it just the way it is
i don't want to cut another tree i don't
want another member i think this is
perfect
right and then there are people and i
probably i'm one of them
you know who come to a community and
kind of see it for what it can become
you know it's like oh we can kind of
clear this area we can create a whole
new nucleus over here or whatever
and we butt heads you know so it's just
natural
there's a there's a saying there's a
japanese saying
that if you want to clean potatoes one
of the ways you do it is you put them
all in a pot of water and you shake
and just by rubbing each other they
clean each other
and people are like that you know and
i i've been very
grateful to see when sometimes someone
comes into a community
and they have some sharp edges you know
they have very strong opinions it's got
to be this way or
the highway or you know and over time
it's wonderful to see them kind of
soften a little bit and round and kind
of you know their communication skills
improve and to me
that's a real fundamental value of
living in communities just that rubbing
and kind of
pissing each other off too is really
helping us become more resilient and
understand how we can communicate and
take others needs and values into
perspective
so it's a challenge yeah but i do think
it's
there probably is a place of too much
community and we haven't even talked
about i mean you could go to the
spectrum of talking about
cults or what does that mean and you
know some people i when i
when the students come on our program i
often ask them like how many of you
in just the whole application and set up
to this process
someone said to you oh you're joining a
culture
and with all of them raised their hands
and to me it's an important
question yeah but for me a cult is
really about
a mindset of restricting individual
growth and freedom
you know you have to think this way and
um you know it's taking away freedoms
and all that and the the programs the
communities we go to it's all about
nourishing growth and freedom and saying
how do we support you become who you
want to be
and so there really is and also cults
are very unfortunate when they show up
in the form of community
but they can also just as easily show up
in a board room
microsoft or military i mean come on uh
schools i mean the cult
we should be looking we should always be
on the lookout for the cult mentality
but it can exist in many areas in our
lives
i don't want to end on that so i'm not
asking questions
one more question
i don't know if there's only that's fine
i'm happy to talk to you
have any experience with any communities
that
um have a specific strong focus on
agriculture i guess i'm thinking like
was the
campbell village steiner biodynamic yeah
there's camp hill they're all over the
world um i actually
where i used to live in southern new
hampshire high mowing and there's a
there's a whole camp hill type place
there
um almost associated with high mowing
seats
no oh i don't know i don't think so no
it's actually a boarding high school
but there's also i can't remember the
name oh it just went through my
mind it has an l in it um but
any eco village or sustainable community
that's worth it salt or that is going to
continue
has to work with food serious
we are challenged because we're on a
hilltop and so
very often you dig down a foot and you
hit bedrock and so we've been building
up the soil
using permaculture methods but we still
produce maybe 30 or 40 percent of our
own food
uh fin horn again does a lot more but
it's not just
its own gardens they work a lot with
surrounding regions
oroville is probably much better at that
i guess they're probably in the 80 to 90
producing their own food
and another important point to make is
that a lot of people think oh it's a
goal of all
eco-villages to be self-sufficient right
to be able to kind of do their own thing
that's not been my experience in fact
it's really the opposite eco villages
that we bring students to are very
porous
and they're often they see themselves as
catalysts
in the region how do we help farmers in
our area
become more organic how do we create
local networks and distribution networks
so that we can
ship goods locally and not have to ship
them from north of india or
overseas or things like that so it's not
just about hey how do we grow more of
our own food
it's how do we create more of a
sustainable bioregion
and maybe maybe that's the unit that we
should be thinking of becoming more
self-dependent or self-sufficient
yeah and certainly there i'm thinking of
other
i can't think off the top my head of
communities that that's their central
focus
they probably are but it's certainly a
focus of everyone
good yeah all right thank you all this
is fun
um yeah i'm gonna be talking at um
alice cook at seven o'clock if you know
anyone
who's interested um so did you ever
get a hold of the eco house no
no i didn't i didn't even remember them
did you just say that
last time i actually stayed there i just
spoke at the eco house at
suny geneseo yesterday so i think yeah
but no that's difficult
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu